hey what's going on is Bilborough and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday my 27th 2000 and was at 17
2007 two [ __ ] decades flying by you
know what I'm - 2011 12 13 can somebody
tell me that 14 was cool vaguely
remember 15 and then 16 you know I want
to thank everyone who wins so much about
it last year the worst year ever
I mean that was pretty vivid a lot of
crying
a lot of crying and I don't mean for the
right reasons like David Bowie and
Prince passing but you know you know
Hillary losing and that type of [ __ ] a
lot of crying a lot of whining um
anyways I uh I don't know what the [ __ ]
to tell you I've been uh being [ __ ]
daddy day care here you know what I did
for the first time we finally went out
right me and me we're going [ __ ]
crazy
cuz you have a baby you have a little
baby yeah I'm a little lady this is the
thing if it's your first kid you [ __ ]
scared to death you're like I can't take
this thing outside it's gonna get a bola
you can all [ __ ] nervous you know
and then it's got to get its [ __ ]
immunizations and all that type of [ __ ]
and you just let go neo who do i [ __ ]
believe here Jesus Christ I'll tell you
those [ __ ] shots this is what I
actually I just sat down I was like
nobody who's ever been in the medical
field told me not to do it I've had
comedians high school friends [ __ ]
actresses a bunch of non doctors have
advised to go what am I not gonna get
her [ __ ] vaccinated for polio no it's
not that what it is is this shut up Nick
do you even own a lab coat all you're
doing is scaring the [ __ ] out of me
so anyways um so we were you know you're
[ __ ] afraid so finally we're just
like alright [ __ ] this we got a stroller
you know so we started taking walks
around the block but my block has like
the shittiest sidewalk it's like you
know the ground
all shifted out here there's tree roots
pushing it up you have no idea when you
just walk it down the street you know
you start pushing the strolling you're
trying to keep the kid quiet you know
because she finally fell asleep it's I
could push on my daughter up the street
it's like [ __ ] like liquid nitrogen
I'm just trying to keep Brian wants to
ever start crying the middle of the
street just going down the street waking
everybody up and I guess they're already
awake I don't know so we finally ended
up going to the mall I had that
experience I went to the mall with my
wife in my kid we pulled in had to take
out a stroller take her out of the car
seat put her in and start walking around
the mall and I gotta tell you it was
[ __ ] awesome I for the first time in
my life I get the mall I get it you know
it's for teenage kids when they're
trying to get away from their parents
like mom just leave me alone
whatever friends that era before you
have a license really you can't really
go anywhere you just need some sense of
[ __ ] freedom and it's for after you
become a parent you have to get out of
the [ __ ] house into some sort of
controlled environment where there's
enough goddamn people that you don't
have to worry about anybody snatching
your goddamn kid you know so we walked
around and just had a great [ __ ] time
was like the perfect day and you know
Nia was all excited to be out because uh
you know women just tell Jesus the [ __ ]
they go through being the guy it's the
best I swear to god it's why they
[ __ ] I think it's why they make our
lives so goddamn miserable is they see
how easy it is and the thing is we don't
realize how easy it is because we've
only been us you don't I mean how long
it takes them to get ready do you how
long it takes me to get ready now I got
a [ __ ] shaved head I mean I've done
even have to do anything
you can literally hose me off in the
backyard and I could you know I'd be
ready in like seven minutes easy
seven minutes because I always got to
run around and find my cell phone for
like five of those minutes but you know
if I if I actually was organized and
knew where all my [ __ ] was I could be I
could be writing like three minutes
anyways yeah they go through all of that
[ __ ] you know and me they got a breast
feed they got together they got a pump
all of that crap I don't have to do any
of that you know what I mean so she was
going [ __ ] nuts dealing with
everything that nature put on her and
she finally had to get out of the house
and now it's the happiest I've seen her
we walked around had a great time you
know what they have it in malls now this
is a second mall I've been to that they
have like a Tesla store like in going
like who the [ __ ] just goes to the mall
and buys a car you know I mean you go
that you buy sunglasses right a [ __ ]
hula hoop whatever whatever it is you
buy it buy a car so I you know I can't
resist I got to go in there right I'm
like what's the deal with this thing
zero to sixty woody woody 2.5 the guys
like 2.30 that's amazing what's up in
San Jose the guy told me 2.5 you shaved
off in another two hundredths of a
second and I'm like all right so I get
four adults in there because you can get
five and I go and I'm still gonna go
zero to 60 in 2.3 seconds it does make
any sense all that wait what am i up to
they're both 2.93
he goes it probably two six it's like
what are you basing that on other than
the fact you want to make a commission
what am i basing mine on I don't [ __ ]
know so he goes alright let's take a
look at this over here I go dude I just
bought a car I love it I'm not gonna buy
a car me tell you right now but I just
want to see you know if I got the car
that I wanted what this thing's gonna
cost me right so I go I go give me the
one with the motor the all-wheel drive
all right
I went black I didn't want to get the
black interior cuz it's hot as [ __ ] out
here right so the guy goes do you want
the [ __ ] the full moon roof and
everything I go dude look at me I'm
almost an albino and I have a shaved
head DD [ __ ] and he goes no no the
tints crazy on it I said alright put it
on the [ __ ] car what do I care I'm
not buying this thing right give me the
best you know best tires best rims best
best [ __ ] everything then they had
this thing oh you know for five grand
when you get on the highway it kind of
drives it kind of helps you and I was
like - why would I buy a car like this
and have something else dry I want to
drive it I don't need that [ __ ] right so
that I didn't get it
thing else I got and in the end I took a
picture of it forget how much it cost I
[ __ ] I don't even exactly nobody in the
end you know what it cost one hundred
and fifty two thousand dollars [ __ ] and
what kills me someone's gonna go to the
mall and buy one of those hundred fifty
two thousand [ __ ] dollars I just wish
they looked cooler
I love the [ __ ] tires and everything
and there's a you know if you get the
right tires and rims and [ __ ] really
help that car and the front end
definitely looks better I don't know man
you know it looks like it looks like
that photo of Porsche that's ugly as
[ __ ] that Panamera whatever that you
know you know they always try to do that
in like the the car commercials will
they have a two-door car they have the
dad then he has the baby and then he
grabs the bumper and he turns it into a
four-door car like oh wow this is like a
sports car but it's a four-door sedan no
what is it it's a four-dose in it and it
won't but that's trying to be a sports
car and then it becomes ugly that's why
I like the Mercedes to BMW in the jet
and the Jaguars because they still look
like cars like four-door sedan then you
step on the gas it's like oh [ __ ] look
at this who knew I'm talking about here
um anyway so we ended up having a great
time and uh I walked by the the [ __ ]
what store is that thing whatever
whoever the one that looks looks like
the letter H it's not Nike or adidas
it's the other one it's the one that
[ __ ] Steph Curry has and in the
window they have these ugly-ass
basketball shoes and I looked at it said
curry threes dude
gun to your head what do you like better
that the Kobe 11s of the curry threes I
don't know dude the curry threes you
know with a [ __ ] crisp pair of jeans
and a hoodie dub over with your chain on
the outside male fashionistas
- Jordan threes all right Jordan trees
okay with the pair of Joe's Jeans all
right and a button down in a new Yankee
dude new Yankee had to and a slice of
pizza that doesn't get any better
[Music]
playing PlayStation on the TV and inside
Dallas Cowboys Stadium crazy ultimate
bachelor party dude a pair of [ __ ]
Jordan nines right jeans cuffed creased
with with an Amber Crombie and Fitch
v-neck t-shirt extra soft playing
PlayStation with the slice of pizza and
a [ __ ] how we say does it get any
better than that dude um sorry I don't
know what it is I like Snickers and I've
actually been buying some I just like
the old ones like I got a pair of shell
toes and I got a pair of early 80s
[ __ ] adidas like high tops like I
like that [ __ ]
like I don't know what that went [ __ ]
Picasso started designing these goddamn
pigs it's like it makes no sense um I'm
gonna get in trouble for [ __ ] I'm gonna
say later on this podcast I I don't know
what the [ __ ] to tell you I got some
shout outs to do I never give shout outs
right and I just had a bunch that was
just piling up and I'm like I finally
got to give out some [ __ ] shout outs
and then but I just never get around to
him it's extra work I never give a [ __ ]
but then finally somebody tip me over
the [ __ ] edge right Laura zygarde I
got it I got to give this person to
shout out all right so first of all
let's let's get the let's get the opener
in the feature out of the way shout out
to Eric it blows for hooking me up with
some of those bows headphones I was
bitching about um people being loud in a
you know on the plane and by the way
this is not so I can get more free [ __ ]
I don't want anymore [ __ ] I'm getting
rid of [ __ ] if you give me free [ __ ] I'm
going to give it away or I'm going to
send it down to [ __ ] Goodwill and
it's going
end up in a truck that sits in a
warehouse and they gonna dump it in the
ocean so I don't want any [ __ ] you know
a nice email hey Bill like his stuff
that's just fine okay but if somebody
did something you got to say thank you
right all right
shout out to Eric it bows and then James
shot well I did this thing this weekend
Rock Against MS where I got to give an
award to Richard Pryor's Widow Jennifer
Pryor and you know Richard suffers from
that disease of course he turned it into
comedy and set out the disease actually
slowed him down so he could live longer
which is really fascinating that that's
probably true and anyways James Shotwell
was down there doing I don't know
working like the sound I got to see all
these [ __ ] killer bands these
amalgams like [ __ ] Alice in Chains
with Nancy Wilson from Hart coming out
crushing it and she brought her new band
out road case Royale and they [ __ ]
killed it dude she's up she's still a
beast I got to see Steven Adler play
with an all-star band he played the hell
did he play he played The Ramones I want
to be sedated and then I got to stand it
like a 10 feet away from him I got to
watch him play welcome to the jungle in
rocket Queen and see all this subtle all
these little subtle things that he's
first of all I get to see all the genius
drum parts that fits so perfectly to
that song and then just the different
ways that he played him you know that
part you know some Dunnan and bah bah
bah bah bah clap it's really I always
thought he was on Bowl Tom's he's just
riding on the floor tom
and on the second snare here comes over
with the phlegm that's that little [ __ ]
when you're a drum nerd like me I'm like
that's how he [ __ ] plays it and I got
the of course he was cool as [ __ ] you
know he's such a [ __ ] great guy man
had you know couple people were there
that had MSE let him [ __ ] sit like
right behind him while he played when he
finished playing he came out he
high-fived everybody in the front row
dude we were at the LA Theatre in
downtown LA and it was um I guess it was
a theater was designed by char
Chaplin okay and when you walk in in the
foyer there's a picture of Charlie
Chaplin walking in the night it first
opened with Albert Einstein and of
course I missed that photo somebody told
me was there but downstairs
they have this kid's room that still has
the original paint so they say don't
touch the walls and of course it's all
these creepy [ __ ] drawings like being
a kid was so [ __ ] scary back then all
these creepy drawings of clowns and
horses and [ __ ] and someone was trying
to claim and I refuse to believe that
this is true that day that's what you
brought your babies when they cried if
they got really loud they had these
little like cabinets you just open the
door and you put the baby in you close
the door it's like even downstairs they
could still hear it I refuse to believe
that that's true but um I ended up
co-hosted it with Craig Gass who that
guy's impressions a [ __ ] unbelievable
man is Sam Kinison his gene Simmons
Sebastian Bach and he's hung out with
all of these guys so he has all these
unreal stories and he does dead-on
impressions and jim Florentine was there
it was an amazing [ __ ] night so thank
you too Nancy sale for putting that
whole thing on and I'll do it any year
that they want and then lastly but lease
Lee um got it we got a actually I got a
request from somebody who says that
she's a fan a lady fan of the podcast
and my stand-up but uh what she
requested I guess is already over uh
she's trying to be a next year's Sports
Illustrated swimsuit lisa marie jatha
but the voting is already closed so I
don't know I don't know if it was real
or not I immediately didn't believe that
it was a real email and then she sent a
video go no seriously I know you're a
bald middle-aged [ __ ] but I actually
like your stuff if you could send your
listeners over to vote for me you know
maybe I can get in the issue next year
and I don't know that's such a weird
world you know what I mean you don't
need that [ __ ] map about that world was
one time
Neah having watched this [ __ ] thing
about it and they had this creep that
was like the go-to guy and he called
himself Uncle Terry anybody who's not
your uncle
ladies anybody who's not your uncle eNOS
just call me uncle so-and-so yeah he's
trying to [ __ ] you
he's a [ __ ] this guy was one of the
creepiest [ __ ] people I've ever seen
in my goddamn life um so anyways
my apologies the voting is already
[ __ ] over but I don't even know if
this I don't even know if it was real to
be honest with you but you know what I'm
a middle-aged bald man and I bets
wanting to believe that that's true is
it that's really all I have um in
speaking of swimsuit models Oh Billy fat
tits hair has been [ __ ] doing great
on the elliptical I'm back in it man I'm
back at it I [ __ ] up last night had a
glass of booze all the booze won last
night I just had a glass which was
probably considered a triple in any
[ __ ] hipster bar but uh I was gonna
go to bed I wasn't gonna have it you
know I've been doing good I stopped
eating at 5:00 and at 11:30
you know me had come home I was hanging
out with my daughter the whole night man
she was a riot she was the right Jesus
Christ dude she had two apocalyptic
[ __ ] diapers yesterday that was just
like it was just like really I don't
think I don't think I don't think I we
bought enough provisions to ever get
this fixed again so um she came home
late and and I was just going to go to
bed and I kept playing that mental
tennis should I have a glass don't have
glass translation glass don't evade it
finally the the booze was just looking
like come on you know the booze was like
it was like Jimmy the gent you know
after they [ __ ] did the lift wanza
heist however you say the bottle is just
over there and going come here yo khmer
yo you know when Henry comes walking in
so I had one so I don't know I'm it like
180 1.2 and I've just been in the 80s I
hate being in the 80s that's when that's
when I just and when I shift my weight
around on the couch just to go reach for
the remote you just feel the rolls going
home on the side of you
you know I don't know how people do it I
don't know you just walk around being a
[ __ ] fat body I don't know why you
tolerate that you got one [ __ ] life
and you know goddamn well in the back of
your head you don't know where you go
after this ok let's say best-case
scenario you get reincarnated all right
because the whole Heaven Hell thing it's
the same thing every day after a while
it's not even to have any value will you
light me on fire again ok what is it
another perfect day oh boy you're going
to be like those teenagers at the mall
oh god I'm so bored right best-case
scenario you get reincarnated the
[ __ ] odds that you're going to come
back again as a human being I mean you
know if you can come back as a [ __ ]
Mouse or some [ __ ] like you know [ __ ]
run around almost having a heart attack
is some reptile is slowly tracking you
getting eaten alive you know this is the
best you got so you can [ __ ] sit here
and become a tub of [ __ ] you don't you
owe it to yourself this is what I've
been doing this has been the breakfast
of a freckled champion
every morning I wake up bow doo doo doo
dude and I go out to the garage and what
do i do i go to i go in the [ __ ]
elliptical as my my rotator cuff is
slowly getting better today i did some
lady push-ups I was gonna do 20 I was
like don't push it stop 212 stop 212
just trying to keep the [ __ ] man tits
from sagging down into my navel I do
like a half hour on the on the
elliptical and then I come in for
breakfast I have one of those little
oranges and I have a poached egg and
that's it and then I have a banana
between there and lunch and then for
lunch I have some sort of protein well
you know maybe with a little bit of
bread some
I know breads the enemy go [ __ ] yourself
it's the only bread I have and then I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is then I
have a protein with the salad at for
protein with the salad at 6:00 and then
I'm done then I just drink waters for
the rest of the night in theory unless
the [ __ ] Jimmy the jet moment happens
and I get [ __ ] over um anyways uh so I
have to do this [ __ ] I got to get my ass
back down I can't my birthday's coming
up in June I'm gonna be 49 [ __ ] years
old which I'm actually pretty uh I'm
alright with it once you have a kid you
can alright with being old you like it
other than that you like yeah I'm 47 on
a kid it's got a dialogue um gonna be 49
and there's no [ __ ] way I'm gonna be
in the 180s it's just not going to
happen I'm telling you right now I am
going to be 172 my fighting weight
that's where the hell I want to be my
shoulders going to be healed and I have
a bet with Paul verzino when I'm 70
years old I'm gonna be able to do 10
pull-ups and if I don't get this rotator
cuff fixed I'm gonna be [ __ ] because
all I keep thinking about is Jordan when
he came back on the Wizards you know and
that was the first time you really saw a
drop-off in his playing level because
not only was he gone for three years he
didn't really play and when you stopped
that's when you [ __ ] that's what I've
learned trying to get it back is is hard
it's really [ __ ] hard although
although D del Rey who crushed it in San
Jose
Dean del Rey in San Jose told me he's
doing sets of 20 [ __ ] pull-ups I've
never done 20 pull-ups in my life
straight I think the most I ever was
able to do is I just can't get past like
16 he's 51 years old can do 20 pull-ups
sets of 20 so there's hope there's
always hope is this like an
inspirational podcast bill used to [ __ ]
on stuff all right I will but I can't I
can't I'm just having a I'm havin you
know I've gotten such so little material
out of having a daughter I thought like
off [ __ ] here we go my whole act is
going to [ __ ] change man
and it's been so awesome you know what
am I gonna do talk about how great it is
somehow get you know I do is I actually
I pretty much my act I just [ __ ] on
people to talk about how difficult
parenting is you know what I mean I'm
not saying yeah it's not I'm not walking
around sleepy or [ __ ] all the time but
you know come on you know go watch that
[ __ ] movie I told you to watch
well they torture that kid that plays
the violin that guy from peaky blinders
is in it anthropoid go watch that
[ __ ] thing
watch what those people went through and
tell me that being a parent is hard
anyways sorry plowing ahead Oh what
happened where do I start
do I talk f1 do I talk about the Celtics
do I talk about the Bruins playing for
their playoff fighting for their playoff
lines
let's talk Bruins then I'll do a little
advertising here the Bruins [ __ ] 84
points we lost four [ __ ] games in a
row
we just won one of those goddamn games
we are now we will like all the way up
to like I think a fourth seat at one
point or a fifth seat we are now in
eighth seat Toronto is ahead of us I
heard that goaltender got hurt though
where the [ __ ] is it I had this goddamn
standings when I wanted I deal with it
anyways
I don't know well we had a huge wing
thank you to riley nash those two
[ __ ] huge goals against the islet is
we got the Predators on tuesday and then
we play the stache is a big [ __ ]
Boston team week dude you're gonna watch
the bees versus the stache so I'm
against the Predators do and I'm going
to go out on a limb and say we kind of
have to win both of those [ __ ] games
or hope everybody beneath this just
keeps losing unreal unreal this is the
third year in a row we're just the
bottoms falling up but you know what I
slowly see improvement though and I can
see how this could be a team that could
actually score a ton of goals in the
future you know I saw on their website
today the up
you know the the Frozen Four is
happening and we got like we have four
prospects in the Frozen Four this year
so who knows I mean the Frozen Four
versus the NHL is a big [ __ ] leap but
who knows who knows maybe there's an
there's an Austin
what the [ __ ] his name Matthews in
there who knows but anyways dude
speaking of that [ __ ] speaking of the
Frozen Four what about the Final Four
I barely paid attention because I've
been run around you know being a dad and
everything but every time I just like
you heard me going Duke lost then my
Kansas lost Kentucky lost the Final
Fours I remember virzi telling me was
its North Carolina understandable South
Carolina Gonzaga and I forget what the
other team is basically there's no
everybody's bracket is [ __ ] at this
point if your bracket isn't [ __ ] if
there's somebody out there that actually
picked this year's final four in the
NCAA you either don't know [ __ ] about
[ __ ] basketball and just guessed or
your dad's in the mob and something's
going down this year because just
everybody's out of it I don't know who
I'm gonna vote for Gonzaga South
Carolina my teams were Duke or Kansas
and I was always like UCLA and they all
got UCLA got [ __ ] knocked out you
know annoyed me that day I was walking
down the street you know cuz all the
bandwagon [ __ ] UCLA fans all of a
sudden buddies rabbit out here you know
what I was wearing a Bruin sweatshirt
and I'm walking down the street and this
guy goes hey goes hates UCLA Bruins not
Boston Bruins I just laughter dad you
guys are good this year he's like yeah
we are and walked away I was like wait a
minute
that was at the car wash and I [ __ ]
looked it up like who was the Bruins
first and it was like UCLA's basketball
team was around before the Boston Bruins
but their first year in like 1918 or
something they were the UCLA Cubs and
then the next year they switched to the
Grizzlies and in like 1928 they joined
I don't know was there was the pack
something pac-10 pac-12 oh I don't what
the [ __ ] it was back then
PAC 8 I have no idea but like there was
some team from Montana that was already
the Grizzlies in a 1928 they switched to
the UCLA Bruins
however the Boston Bruins were in 1924
all right so all due respect to Coach
wooden all due respect to the UCLA
program I actually liked the school and
everything but when it comes to that
Bruin [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
all right we were there first okay so
you stand the [ __ ] down
it's a different sport it's a pro sport
so relax you know
you know bad I've been replaying that in
my head that I wish that I had that
information you know I wish they were in
the Final Four and I would actually I'm
such an argumentative [ __ ] I would
actually [ __ ] maybe drive over to Wes
wooden gets some air-quote lunch and
just walk around with that shirt it's
like it'd be like ah 1944 versus 34 you
with it cause then you would be crazy
hey know your history know your history
you know like like I'm the [ __ ] the
sports guru like I didn't look that [ __ ]
up cuz some guy was a [ __ ] Amina the car
wash
alright let's do some reads here for
this week YouTube channel announcement
oh yeah I got to do that too all right
the internet privacy now these are the
reads for this week this is the [ __ ]
that people sent in oh here we go
wink everybody wi n [ __ ] see wink
finding a new wine is tough especially
for shit-faced that's why I've been
telling you all about our sponsored Club
da club javi I'm not getting drunk again
time that president doesn't care and how
they make it so easy to get wine
personalized to your palate and
delivered right to your door and here's
a little update for you Club Debbie
fighting terror fighting terror
everywhere everything the trees man is
now called wink spell winc a new name
and improved look but here's the
important part it's the same amazing
wine company introducing you to new ones
you love
wink works directly with winemakers and
offers and growers from all over the
world
to create delicious wine and deliver it
right to your door
Winx 100% satisfaction guarantee means
if you don't like a bottle they send you
that will price it with the bottle you
love no questions asked if I was a
[ __ ] alcoholic which I might be that
is the loophole right there
how much of the bottle you get to finish
yeah I didn't like it send me another
you know just get set random bottles
winked it's personalized wine membership
that recommends wine specifically for
you based on the results of your palate
and Profile quiz you can also rate the
wine you receive from Winx so they learn
about ya they basically figure out what
you like and then you always be having a
great bottle of wine then you start
boozing like [ __ ] earnest Hemmingway
the best part is wink is offering my
listeners $20 off right now when you go
to to try wink winc comm / / they'll
even cover the shipping think about that
you're done you'll get fine wine
personalized to your palate delivered
right to your door tri wink and get $20
off plus complimentary shipping right
now when you go to try wink calm that's
try wink calm t ry winc calm / / oh look
who's back look who's back it's our old
friends old zip
are you hiring do you know where to well
are you do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates posting
your job in one place isn't enough to
find quality candidates if you want to
find the perfect hire you need to post
your job on all the top job sites and
now you can with zip group com you can
post your job at 200-plus job sites
including social media networks like
Facebook and the Twitter all with a
single click find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide just post once
you come and watch your qualified
candidates roll into all zip there it is
easy-to-use interface no juggling emails
or calls to your office quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person fast find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by Fortune 100
companies not 500 fortune 100 this is
the top 100 companies of all time and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses everybody's using it and
right now my listeners can try jobs on
zip recruiters for free by going to zip
recruit accom / / that zip recruiter com
/ / one more time try for free go to zip
[Music]
dark cop / purple all right Dollar Shave
Club do do you like shaving your face
you know I want to cut it up well I got
the raises for you there's no reason to
use cheap disposable razors or pay
ridiculously high prices kid for some
gimmicky thing that's got a laser
pointing in 17 [ __ ] blades there make
us mad a choice in joint Dollar Shave
Club all right
what are you doing they're overpriced
you always knew they were it's a piece
of [ __ ] plastic with sharpened
aluminum in it
should it be ninety thousand dollars
wouldn't it be great if they just
delivered it right to your [ __ ] door
what this thing offers that service
before Dollar Shave Club who was he like
I just said all that [ __ ] okay I said it
my own way all right
get a closed smooth shave every time and
you can't beat the convenience or the
price of the club if you haven't tried
Dollar Shave Club yet you're missing out
it's an amazing shape and affordable at
an affordable price
there's no smart smarter choice in the
market right now they're giving away a
one-month trial of any razor for only $1
with free shipping and after that it's
just a few bucks a month there's no long
term calm commitment this is a one-night
stand no hidden fees you get the door
man five bucks you're in and you can
cancel whenever you want you know you
can go bar-hopping get one get your $1
trial at dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / uhm alright
helix hellix this is the last one oh god
I love that they're making the copy is
shorter and shorter for me
you're unique you're special you're your
own snowflake you don't walk like anyone
else talk like anyone else you check
always that always sounds like that
drill sergeant [ __ ] to me remember then
I'm gonna teach you Oh huh your mothers
are not pepper demo I'm gonna teach you
how to walk talk chimp check Padrino
check my car um you don't want like
anyone else you don't talk like anyone
else or sleep like anyone else so why is
your mattress one size fits all because
a truly customized mattress will cost
you five to ten thousand dollars
till now $10,000 for [ __ ] mattress I
just refuse to believe it that's true
that should come with a lady giving you
a [ __ ] hand job
right before sleep you go to helix calm
hellix answer a few simple questions and
they'll run a 3d biomechanical model of
your body through their proprietary
algorithms they've developed with the
help of the world's leading era gamma
sand biomechanics experts the results -
why don't you just stretch a little you
twist it up [ __ ] the fact that they got
to sit there and act like you're in the
Star Wars the result the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept
on you could also stretch everybody if
you stretch and then get one of these
mattresses I think you're going to be
good go get a massage you know drink
some [ __ ] water ten grand for a
mattress just have some [ __ ] Asian
lady walk on your back a little bit save
some money Hilux customers report a 30
30 percent improvement in overall sleep
quality it has to be an Asian lady okay
because their dainty you can't get one
of those American we can't get some
white woman you know you can t any other
races they're going to be too thin less
there then I could be old enough to be
in there you know what I mean they think
it's going to be too goddamn dense they
could be full of [ __ ] growth hormones
and that they're gonna break you back
you know that is an exclusive dainty
Asian lady I just thought about that
I've never seen any any footage of a
white lady walking on somebody's back
you feeling alright alright yeah alright
your mattress arrives at your door at
about a week and shipping is 100% free
he looks uh and four couples they
customized each side of the mattress
that's why everyone from GQ magazine's
to Forbes are talking about helix slash
Alex sleep customizing both sides your
mattress I can't tell if that's gonna
make your relationship happier or it's
the beginning of the end oh god I don't
even like the way he sleeps it'll be
great do I just want to test out what
it'd be like to sleep in a different bed
with him but still be in the same bed
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helix sleep
Alex you have 100 nights to try it out
and if you
love it they'll pick it up for free
gross and give you a 100% refund no
questions asked we don't even want to
know what that stain is we're not going
to ask you go to HELOCs sleep calm slash
burn and get $50 off your order
that's helix sleep dot-com slash bar hey
HELOCs leap comm slash burn all right
there you go just like that we're done
with the advertising we're done with the
advertising and we're on the other side
of the half hours we're gonna do traffic
on the sixes anybody out on the 405 you
might want to get yourself a helicopter
there's a lot of traffic everybody
slowing down watching somebody change a
tire anyways let's talk some f1 action
did anybody did you watch the Australian
Grand P Grampy Grand Prix down in
Melbourne Australia it was a great
[ __ ] race and it lived up to the hype
that this year the Ferraris were going
to be good now I've only watched this
sport for one season so I don't know
[ __ ] about it all I know is last year it
was all about the Mercedes team Lewis
Hamilton Nico Rosberg
you know they had the whole Days of
Thunder you know I'm the guy who's been
around the block on the other [ __ ] I'm
on the Tom Cruise guy somebody's [ __ ]
Robert Duvall and everybody else which
is watching last year and if those two
guys didn't hate each other it would
have been [ __ ] boring as [ __ ] because
basically every race was a race to the
first corner whoever got there first was
just driving through clean air and the
cars were so equally matched nobody
could catch up with somebody you
basically had to [ __ ] up where your car
died so all the exciting racing was like
four you know fourth fifth sixth place
or whatever three psychos going after it
for the last you know championship point
as they say you know back in 10th place
that was exciting but up front it was
just Lewis Hamilton or Nico Rosberg just
just doing laps was you know kind of got
a little boring so this year they were
talking about how Ferrari was very quiet
eerily quiet during the offseason
working on their dirt dirt suspension
and the engine and all that type of [ __ ]
with the new regulations whatever the
[ __ ] they are I don't know what the
and that they were going to make a
serious challenge for uh against
Mercedes this year so the [ __ ] race
starts and the Australian dude I already
forget his name
Rico Rican burg I have no [ __ ] idea
like eventually I'll get these people's
name stuff Rikki Rockett I forget okay
everybody wanted him to win the poor
bastard he's down there and they're
taken like the the warm-up lap or
whatever and not even the warm-up lap
they're just going around getting ready
to get into position just to do the
warm-up lap and his car gets stuck in
6th gear we've all been there right the
side of the highway except he's got a
hundred thousand people in a [ __ ]
zillion millions of fans around the
world watching the [ __ ] so they got to
push his car and they got to take out
the [ __ ] transmission in like five
minutes throw a new one in there try get
it back in the [ __ ] car before the
race starts
that alone if they just showed that that
would have been amazing they kind of
kept cutting back to it I wish it showed
more of it long story short he wasn't
able to get out there until the second
lap she was already two laps down so
that kind of sucked for all the
Australian fans and then his car [ __ ]
the bed halfway through the race however
so the race [ __ ] starts alright
I think Lewis Hamilton had the pole and
then Sebastian Vettel
for Ferrari was in second place and
Lewis had a great start and he was out
front and I go well I guess that's it I
guess the Mercedes are going to win it
this year right so they get about twenty
laps in and Lewis Hamilton pits it's one
of these races was like 57 laps and the
announcers were saying that they were
going to pit one time and it's all when
you pit and bla bla bla bla bla so all
this [ __ ] is becoming fascinating to me
so Lewis Hamilton goes into pit right
Sebastian Vettel was I don't know how
far behind couple seconds behind he
decides to stay out there so the whole
time when Lewis was out there in first
place Sebastian's behind him alright so
Lewis is driving in the clean air it's
like you know if you're on a [ __ ] on
a lake and your brain it's just still
water you could you could go way faster
in your boat as opposed if the water was
all [ __ ] choppy you got to go slow
that's the same thing accepted to its
wit with air I'm just saying this for
everybody else out there who's dumb like
me and the fact that air is invisible
you don't understand it
so no matter what this guy is doing
sebastian vettel he can only get so
close to to Lewis Hamilton because all
the air coming off of him and I guess
the tires are bigger this year which
causes more turbulence it would actually
he's going to use more fuel and chew up
more of his tires if he gets too close
to him which is really [ __ ] I don't
know I don't know if that's a good or a
bad thing
so Hamilton was having problems with the
tire heap it's early so the Ferrari team
takes a gamble and says [ __ ] this we're
going to stay out there so Sebastian now
is in first place driving into clean air
he's got the nice smooth Lake he's
bringing the boat across except it's a
car and it's going through air he's
still with me and he stays out there for
one lap and they go he's definitely
gonna come in for the second lap
meanwhile Lewis Hamilton came right back
out of the pits and then was you know
technically in fourth place but he's you
know but he already pitted the other two
guys in front of him have to pit and so
does the other guy so technically it's
like he's still in first place but now
he's driving in dirty air back there so
Sebastian's flying around the track he
goes around a second time and you know
the tires are getting chewed up he's
driving like a [ __ ] maniac and then
the he comes around a third time and
they're like he's not gonna he's not
going to [ __ ] stay out there he
stayed out there again and now basically
it was like this was the most exciting
part of it cuz this is the [ __ ] race
so basically he's trying to he's trying
to get out so far ahead that he has time
to pit when he goes in get his tires and
get back out on the track in front of
[ __ ] Lewis Hamilton it was like a
[ __ ] movie he pulls in his fourth
time around comes in they [ __ ] take
the tires though you gotta go so [ __ ]
slow too now is he he got to slow down
to like like you driving a Prius when
you're in there and as he's slowing down
this show and Lewis is coming around
he's coming around he's coming around
he gets the tires [ __ ] Sebastian's
coming out it's like a [ __ ] action
movie and it was literally he just
Sebastian uh for Ferrari just got out in
front of Lewis Hamilton and then that
was the race he saw the Mercedes guy
slammed his hand down on the guy in the
pits right the head [ __ ] guy right
the guy goes the eyes wide shut
Illuminati parties at the end of the
[ __ ] race right they're probably on
some yacht
that's like invisible like the air that
they drive to right he [ __ ] slammed
his hand down like medium and then
[ __ ] slammed it down a second time
right there I was like this guy knows
this [ __ ] race is over and that was
it Ferrari won the first race you know
backing up their lack of [ __ ] talk they
were real quiet the offseason so I was
actually really you know I like blame
I'm one of those guys I like both both
team Mercedes and Ferrari me I don't
know how you get mad at either one of
them the [ __ ] beautiful amazing cars
that they built all this [ __ ] over
the years so I'm just happy that this
seems like there's going to be
competition and if it can be as exciting
as that for the whole season
I think maybe some more you guys can get
into it like I did I believe the next
race is in China in Indo jido
in China um that's going to be the next
one but I was I was thrilled with the
race I don't have any f1 fans listen to
this [ __ ] I love to hear your thoughts
on it all right what else what else the
Celtics won the Celtics are technically
in first place right now but we got two
games at hands we've one more one more
game and lost one more game
then the Cavaliers but uh I mean I don't
I don't see them not the Cavaliers not
getting the number one seed unless they
get real I don't know if somebody gets
[ __ ] her to some [ __ ] like that all
right last announcement and then I'm
gonna read the your [ __ ] emails for
the week are at my youtube channel that
I'm slowly but surely building up all
right now I'm gonna uh I'm gradually
just transitioning to the [ __ ]
Internet here my whole career is just
going to be on the internet internet
other than my live dates and f is for
family because everything else is drying
up so my youtube channel which I'm
serious about building up with content I
actually hired a animator and I had a
couple of people to start making videos
and putting content up there I'm gonna
be doing tours of
city that I go to now I'm bringing those
things back I'm actually considering
bring it on this guy that does drum
covers that looks like me but you know
isn't me but maybe it's me so anyways
what do we got here on Tuesday the first
video from Allen Palin pronounced Palin
on the official podcast Channel Allen
Palin is the guy who edited together
remember that one when i commentated
basketball he's the guy who did that so
we're gonna have new videos from him
every single week my YouTube page is
youtube.com slash user slash it's back
slash you know the one that starts
further away and then comes in towards
you like a flare chop youtube.com
backslash users backslash Monday morning
podcast please subscribe to the channel
check it out and I'm going to start
making some videos and that type of [ __ ]
I don't know that I'll have a video take
the podcast because it's just me laying
here right now I'm wearing a t-shirt
pajama bottoms and slippers how
interesting is that going to be and I
everytime I whenever I saw radio shows
videotaped they just something happen
where was boring I like the fact that
like podcast it's just like radio and
the fact that you're doing [ __ ] right
now
you driving home from work you're on the
[ __ ] elliptical you know you're
pouring yourself a drink you clean in
the house whenever you're doing whatever
the [ __ ] it is you doing you can do
other [ __ ] right all of a sudden it's
video tape you feel you got to watch
somebody talking into a microphone I
don't get it all right here we go
Internet privacy everybody hey Billy
thought you might like this a private
Internet access provider took out a
full-page ad in The New York Times
calling out 50 senators who voted to
monitor monitor the public's internet
activity for financial gain what people
care a lot about their public image and
I think this should be done more to
combat [ __ ]
let me call let me click on this thing I
can't click on it because I'm not on the
Internet
hang on let me try and find this here I
got to see who the cons are who are the
[ __ ] that sign tit onto this
we are the [ __ ] we don't give a [ __ ]
alright hello world these are the 50
senators who monitor devoted to monitor
your internet activity not Jesus Christ
I can't read on the to [ __ ] small
alright oh Jesus Jesus what are they all
Republicans dude the way they vote man
because it was probably something else
that was Pro conservative that's the
only reason why the [ __ ] Democrats
didn't it's still [ __ ] Hatfield and
McCoys it's basically there it's all
Republicans representative from
Tennessee Alexander representative from
Wyoming Barrasso Blount from Missouri
Boozman from Arkansas burner from North
Carolina you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
ruining the name Caputo from West
Virginia Cassie from Louisiana Cochran
from Mississippi Collins from Maine
corker from Tennessee you know I'm just
gonna I'm going to just retweet this
[ __ ] picture Jesus Christ Republicans
all Republicans Cruz from Texas Crapo
from some element names Danes from
Montana
another one from Wyoming Enzi from
Wyoming Ernst from Iowa this is all of
this [ __ ] all Rubio from Florida Perdue
from Georgia Portman from Ohio this is
all like this is all saying it's fake
news it's all fake news you know it's
basically you know who's canoed news
it's propaganda it's [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] but what they want is their
[ __ ] in your brain that's what they
want so what they want to do is
gradually take control of this [ __ ] and
they're going to make fake news
basically your opinion of what's going
on they're going to make that like
illegal to do and they're probably
looking over at China going like hey
China
[ __ ] did you do this and China's going
like I this is how we did it
so they gradually do that much like the
Nazis we're looking at us going like hey
how did you do that [ __ ] to the Native
Americans because we want to do that to
the Jews now we're gonna do that
probably what looking I bet I bet the
[ __ ] higher up 1% [ __ ] the people
who make profit off a war and
everybody's misery I bet they are
envious of the internet in Red China the
way you know you are I is envious when
somebody drives down the strip I you
know [ __ ] Ferrari you know I don't
know all right well I'm good for that
person that put that up there
that's [ __ ] disgusting I wonder what
was linked to it though you know what I
mean because it's never just in defense
of all of those [ __ ] people it's
never just one thing which is another
[ __ ] thing you know when when they
vote for something they shouldn't just
be one thing should we or should we not
vote for solar power it should just be
about that but then they tag all this
other [ __ ] onto it onto the bill which
is [ __ ] that's how they get
everything through and then it's always
like you know something completely
[ __ ] up and then when that person goes
to run for office you know they voted
for the bill because they're into solar
power but then the thing that the
appendix that they put onto it they can
be like this guy doesn't dig kid should
have ice cream he voted against that
it's like no I voted for alternative
sources of energy to bankrupt the the
terrorists terrorists
all right bullying manager dear bill
about a month ago a lady Dairy Queen
manager in Missouri was charged for
involuntary manslaughter
what uh she gave the guy an ice-cream
headache does she did he bean ice-cream
that'll blow you the guy fell for and he
stuck his head into the [ __ ] smoothie
machine the soft-serve there all right
allegedly the Dairy Queen manager was a
dick to one of its employees filled with
name-calling and belittling day after
day isn't it great to see women getting
like positions of power and just acting
exactly he's [ __ ] ridiculous as men
you know most most people cannot handle
a position of power I mean look at me
look at the power I have with this
podcast I don't have the decency to put
on pants I'm in pajamas and slippers I
am part of the problem one incident
reportedly the manager threw a burger on
the floor after he made it incorrectly
and then made the seventeen-year-old
clean it up the kid was also a victim of
bullying at school as well none of this
is going to justify this kid harming
this boss you you quit the job but
voiced most of the bullying but voiced
most that does make it sense but most of
the bullying happened happened at work
what happened to this person who wrote
this sentence they wrote but voiced most
of the bullying happening at work and
singling singling out his boss out his
boss okay well eventually the kid ended
up shooting himself in the head oh boy
did not see that coming yes I know it's
a sad story that aught that happens too
often does it do a lot of people get
bullied at Dairy Queen and then blow
their brains out I thought that was a
happy place
they got soft-serve ice cream what could
go wrong but the town wanted to hold
some be responsible for his suicide the
authorities air-quote investigated and
interviewed people and his stories of
being teased and made fun of were retold
the cops ultimately came to the
conclusion that his Dairy Queen boss was
the reason the kid is dead how about
Jesus Christ wait him in a a little bit
of an overreach and she was charged with
secondary and voluntary manslaughter
after me hearing this story is that
proper English shouldn't be after I
heard this story after for me after
hearing this story I'm waiting for
somebody on TV to state the the obvious
this is bull
[ __ ] how can you blame someone for
another person killing themselves it's
not my fault how other people handle my
insults you've been called Billy fat
tits how many times well first of all
I'm not 17 all right I think enough
bullying can drive somebody to it it
depends on how it is and and how fragile
somebody is but there's just so many
[ __ ] variables involved like what had
the person let's say this person was a
bully at Dairy Queen like what happened
to them as a kid that made them the way
they are how old is this person because
for me I just feel that I honestly
believe that you know people in their
20s for the most part it's just it's
that is the most purest form of the
direct results of the parents that you
had is now you're out in the world
they're not there to be like hey hey hey
you know knock it off
you know and you have to make decisions
for yourself and you go around like I
know when I was in my 20s I took without
realizing it I was taking my everybody
takes their childhood out on people in
their 20s because you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're doing
so hopefully you had a good one so you
taking it out on people is is you're
actually a nice person like Pete Holmes
his character on crashing by the way I
[ __ ] love that show
TJ Miller Artie Lange and I believe the
guy's name is George basil I watched the
first three [ __ ] episodes and they
were killing me and their interaction
with Pete's character is great and I
can't wait I love Pete Holmes I cannot
wait to break his balls about his
character on that show though I'm really
going to break his balls like Pete is
that how you see yourself I'm just a
nice guy who tries to do nice things
it's like Pete you're a [ __ ] lunatic
just like the rest of us anyways all I
can't wait to I think one of my favorite
things in this business is teasing him
because he can [ __ ] take it but
you got to check out crashing jenna
Apatow Pete Holmes
Joey roses Joe DeRosa wrote on the show
to Mike Birbiglia I believe wrote on the
show there's a bunch of people comics
and everything and comics on it
I saw Agria bonds dove Davidoff all
these comics marina Franklin it's just
[ __ ] them it's such an amazing show
cuz I remember when he came to New York
as that wide-eyed kid and I had actually
worked with him and this comedy club in
Peoria Illinois that doesn't exist
anymore I worked with him at Brewster's
when he was still married I believe
maybe he just gotten divorced I can't
[ __ ] remember I've told this story
before we went to go see the ring and we
and we were the only two people in the
movie theater and I hate that that's
that that is the detail because that
sounds fake it's the only time it's ever
happened we walked in a shitty movie
theater we were two comedians it was the
middle of the [ __ ] it was like 2:00
in the afternoon we saw the ring on like
a Thursday afternoon in a shitty movie
theater and I swear to God with you only
two [ __ ] people there that movie
stayed with me certain certainly Blair
Witch stayed with me that one stayed
with me some of them just to just they
just [ __ ] creeped me out and they
stay with me for whatever reason Jordan
peels movie when that that guy comes
running when the kids smoking the
cigarette and then the guy comes [ __ ]
just running up full speed at him that
[ __ ] with me that's for whatever
reason that [ __ ] stayed with me
anyways disliked [ __ ] I think about when
I go to my car at night even though I
know it's not real I just think about
what if that [ __ ] dude just came
running just like that at the last
second made a right turn in front of me
um anyways how the [ __ ] did I get onto
all of that [ __ ] talking about this poor
kid who killed himself um anyways you
can said they're throwing uh okay where
does he say you've been called Billy fat
tits how many times and by how many
people you kill yourself over half of
your listeners will go to jail how is
this a law how many times can you call
somebody fat before it's against the law
and
can we stop saying bullying it's just
being teased and made fun of that's not
true man that isn't that's not true
that's not true it depends on the level
and it depends on the intent and all of
this [ __ ] will be really hard to prove
but like you know there's what it is sir
is you have to have empathy here and
what I'm guessing is is that you were
more the person teasing than getting
teased maybe you were a little bit more
of a stronger person the same way
somebody else might have just been
better at math than you I know looking
back you know in my high school I know
that there was uh you know there was
kids that got it really [ __ ] bad
really bad and uh you know one of them
you know killed himself a few years
later and I remember thinking back I
don't know what it was based on but
certainly did not have a good experience
in high school the last couple of years
and it's one of those things because
kids are kids and they don't they don't
understand it
it's a really complex thing but I would
say if this kid was also bullied at
school and then if this person was a
Content at Dairy Queen I mean it's sort
of an amalgam of all of that and then
also the personality some people they're
born they're just really sensitive shy
people and they don't know how to handle
it and if you're prone to depression
should I imagine that you know that's
sort of the perfect storm so anyways he
goes they throw this bullying word
around like it's an epidemic sweeping
all these heartless Millennials we've
all been made fun of before we've all
been called names ever since we were
little kids you sound like an older
person like me and you're just doing the
day these kids today these Millennials
and oh my god they're fragile little
flowers and they're not all like that
dude this do you think there's still not
the mean kid you still don't think
there's this you know the big guy just
[ __ ] beating on this always gonna be
the bigger kid beating on the younger
kids the smaller kids or whatever we
need to let this continue it builds care
if you were always given a trophy you're
all over the map here dude it only told
compliments you you wouldn't be a
comedian no now you're speaking for me
you would still be working in the
carpeted area discussing which I never
worked there your favorite route to work
in the morning all I'm saying is that
we're all becoming weak [ __ ] because
of laws like this and nobody's
addressing it but you can bill with your
soon-to-be Emmy winning podcast you can
champion this cause for all our sakes or
whatever I hope to see important soon
thanks I have to be honest with you sir
all right I think the true sign of
maturity
aside from on one side being able to
take a good ribbing and and learning how
to have more of a sense of humor about
yourself
and also learning that whatever is
happening today is not the end of the
[ __ ] world and that you know there's
probably kids listening right now that
get bullied this is thing all of that
[ __ ] it's you're not going to see any of
those [ __ ] people ever again after
high school and your whole [ __ ] life
is going to be determined by you and the
decisions you make and you have 100%
control over that so you know and I
think a lot of times people get bullied
out the side from the fact that they're
that they're just smaller weaker they
just seem like targets I think you know
sometimes when people see somebody
that's talented they'll go after them
and so you got to make sure that you
kind of push all that [ __ ] away
but the other side I think that really
shows that you're mature is is empathy
you know what I mean it certainly helps
like I can think it's easy to do that
the rant that you did I understand
there's a lot of truth in some of the
[ __ ] to you saying but you know it's not
all just like I'll learn how to [ __ ]
take it you [ __ ] [ __ ] stop wearing a
helmet when you ride bicycles and [ __ ]
and I'm guilty of saying stuff like that
I understand where you're coming from
but like you know so what what is what
what why do you think this kid killed
himself
you don't I mean do you think if that
[ __ ] wasn't happening the kids still
what if I mean it's a possibility on our
off it kid had clinical depression I
have no idea but I agree with you to try
from what you've written for the
sentences where the was spelled
correctly it seems like that kid was
just having a miserable experience I
mean I can't imagine if you were getting
bullied all day at school and then you
go okay well now I'm going to get a job
this might be a ray of light to what the
future is going to be where I'll be at
work and maybe people are nicer and then
it just becomes somebody else screaming
at you you know when you're 17 years old
if it sucks at school and sucks at the
Dairy Queen you work at that is your
world and you don't have an ability to
step out of it and you can downward
spiral like once again I don't think
that they should put it all on this
person but that's a [ __ ] terrible
story but I don't think this backlash to
the tutu political correctness to then
go the other [ __ ] decody all the way
back once again to what cause political
correctness all you [ __ ] guys a pull
your bootstraps up stop being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] millennial flower it's
guys like you that are [ __ ] ranting
against [ __ ] political correctness
it's console IQ that created political
correctness
you know white guys that tell it like it
is is there anything worse than the
white guy that I I know I always say
that I [ __ ] it's that is to me that
is the most boring [ __ ] mindset you
could possibly have a I'm a white guy
everything's set up for me let me tell
you who you know does not have the
advantages that I have why you need to
toughen up you know as I slept in my
bunk bed in my cul-de-sac those were the
years that I really became a tough guy
anyway so yeah I mean that's just a
terrible story I I I hope that you know
some good can come out of it because
that's you know it's very rare that you
know you bring up an ice cream store and
something like that happens that was all
excited you know I love [ __ ] Dairy
Queen
you know my wife loves Dairy Queen we
are Dairy Queen people cleaning up all
right dear bill dear Billy red face yeah
I'm 52 years old
congratulations most people don't live
that long a lot of people don't make it
that far uh I'm 52 years old but a life
of drinking has made me look 62 I still
drink and I smoke weed all day Jesus
guys going hard you drink and you smoke
weed all day I wasn't there for my kids
growing up they had to go through a lot
because of my mind and my wife's
addiction problems Jesus I imagine they
did let's just say Jesus is too
depressing ones in a row what is this
dr. Phil you need to stop drinking smoke
and wait and pay attention to your
children crowd goes crazy another
episode in the can and he gets more
syndication money and then that [ __ ]
drunk walks out the door continues to do
what the [ __ ] he's doing and dr. Phil
looks great let's just say the fact that
they turned out let's just fight say the
fact that they the way they turned out
has nothing to do with me I take no
credit for the people they are today
well nor should you with the exception
of any lingering anxiety I may I may
have caused them I mean if you're the
kind of dad that you're saying you were
yeah you kind of own it up to it which
is good I guess unless you're doing that
like so every goes no no you were
actually a good dad all depends on what
your your reasoning is um I don't live
close to my daughters but I am starting
to miss them I feel like they'd be
better without me at this point
aw I'm at a fork in the road I can
either clean up and realize that my life
isn't over it's not my phone buzzing ah
when he spills his first glass of water
of the day all right I gotta [ __ ]
call this back in a minute
um all right where am I I can either
clean up and realize that my life isn't
over and then I may have the
grandchildren one day that I want to
have a relationship with or just enjoy
my responsibility list life
responsibilities less life until I die
this sounds morbid and the answer may
seem more obvious
to someone else but there is a good
chance my kids won't care either way at
this point and I don't want to disrupt
them by being the annoying hey can I
come back into your life person quitting
won't be easy and I'm trying to weigh my
options what should I do
you should get clean and sober and own
up to everything apologize to your kids
and then understand that it's your kid's
choice whether they want you back in
their life or not and that's what they
decide that they don't you have to be a
man about it and I wouldn't pout and go
back to drinking and smoking
you can totally clean your life up and
you can put years back on the odometer
you know or you can be dead in ten years
I mean it's up to you I mean it's pretty
pretty easy easy choice but I would say
the first thing you should do is try to
get help and I don't know I got to tell
you do not drinking and all that type of
stuff you feel like you feel like a
million bucks you know for days and not
drinking alone when you wake up in the
morning you're gonna feel 20 years
younger you know so I know you want to
keep feeling like [ __ ] it's gonna that's
gonna be a brutal deathbed dude just
sitting there waiting for someone to
show up hoping something's gonna show up
you don't want that man you're only 52
you know you got a lot of years left you
got a quarter of a century left if you
eat right and exercise and all of that
type of stuff so you know it's up to you
man you're an adult I hope you make a
positive choice Jesus Christ all right
yogurt does anybody die in this one um
maybe it's more than you want to bother
but it's really easy to make your own
yogurt then you know what's in it
I'm not going to down going to load you
down with links but this is a pretty
decent start
yeah and they sent me this [ __ ] video
of this woman immediately I'm envious of
her chipper kitchen and the fact that
she could just she can speak more than
one language because I think that's cool
with [ __ ] but uh she's making yogurt and
one of the thing one of the ingredients
she goes is very simple yogurt one of
the ingredients she makes one of the
ingredients to her yogurt is yogurt I'm
going to show you how to make chicken
all right
get salt and pepper put it in a bowl and
then go
to the store and buy some chicken some
already made chicken I don't get it I
don't get that video I'm fine with just
the Greek yogurt probiotic it tastes
[ __ ] weird as [ __ ] the plain stuff
and after a while you get addicted to
when you love it so I appreciate it I
will post the link it's a great [ __ ]
it's you know I love about that stove
it's got four burners and it's got the
griddle in the middle I love that oh I
want that stove so [ __ ] bad
alright fun car to drive Billy sports
car you were talking about cars on
Thursday the most fun car I ever drove
was a 1968 Alfa Romeo sedan not the
spider Google it short throw manual
shift my favorite [ __ ] thing ever
handles great uh yeah I actually
actually looked up the car that we have
there was only YouTube videos pictures
of them nobody had the sedan I'll tell
you one of the best most fun shifting
cars I ever drove was my older brother
had a head like a 1981 two-door Toyota
Tercel 4-speed and that [ __ ] thing it
was so tight it was dude you had to move
that [ __ ] thing like I swear to God
like an inch and a half and you were in
another gear and even always a
four-cylinder by today's standards you
know it was a pretty goofy looking car
set high up off in [ __ ] but it was fun
as [ __ ] to drive we have these jobs with
you know we had paper roots from the
time we were in third grade right up til
ninth grade and then when we got our
licenses we just delivered bigger roots
and we drove around beating the [ __ ] out
of our cars and that was the most fun
car to drive because you could stack at
the back seat up with all the papers and
and dude it was a Toyota and that's when
Toyota was really competing with the
American [ __ ] and the only way that they
were going to get it are you [ __ ]
kidding me are you [ __ ] kidding me
dude this is how [ __ ] up my houses I
just spilled water and I was just like
you know what on the hardwood floors I'm
gonna finish the podcast I'm almost done
I got take I can't believe this just
happened and I'm thinking that the
[ __ ] water is gonna be on the floor
it's just going to be a puddle
this is what just happened I just looked
down at the floor I feel I spilt a full
glass of water it's all gone it's not
there anymore sorry I put the headphones
back on the [ __ ] outta the floor isn't
even wet this is what happens and this
is only one part of my house the house
is settled so much my house is 94 years
old this year it's settled so much that
I swear to god the water rolled down the
hill and the baseboard there's a space
between the floor parts and the
baseboard and it just rolled into the
cracks and disappeared this can't be
[ __ ] happen un-fuckin'-believable
well I got it now I'm wondering where
did that go is the ceiling below now
gonna have all water marks on it I don't
think that's enough water to do it dude
I'm telling you I'm telling you right
[ __ ] now
okay the next house I get is gonna be
[ __ ] if it's an old house it's gonna
be we looked at one this weekend where
it was we're just looking when it would
[ __ ] you know I mean um but just
trying to see what's out there what the
prices are in that type of [ __ ] do we
looked at one it was the turnkey that's
what I want and for all you people never
bought a house that means the whole
[ __ ] thing has been redone I don't
give a [ __ ] that somebody's flipping it
I don't give a [ __ ] that they're trying
to make [ __ ] five hundred [ __ ]
thousand dollars in two months I don't
care the fact that they're gonna strip
it all the way down all the way down all
the piping the sewer line right out to
the [ __ ] Street everything's brand
new that's the house I'm getting that's
the house I'm getting and that's the
house I'm dying in and when I die the
[ __ ] next person can deal with
whatever [ __ ] I did to it I just
built a full glass of [ __ ] water and
it disappeared like a magic trick all
right that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on on
Thursday go Bruins